What is your view on psychological egoism?
If we're all ultimately acting out of self interest,
then does altruism have any merit?
I don't think the questions well post and that's,
it's one of those questions that leads into a philosophical,
a dead end because it's not well post you.
There isn't any such thing as self interest.
It's not the right way to think about it because you're not alone.
And so this is why like Piaget,
John Piaget cause he thought about this intelligently look first of all,
who self interests do you meet?
Do you mean your immediate self interest in the next second?
So that would be impulsive pleasure.
We're all acting for the gaining of impulsive pleasure and to hell with
everything else.
Well obviously that's a stupid way to behave because everyone knows that because
you can do impulsive,
short term gratifying things like snort cocaine now and you can keep doing that
and pay off real,
real well in the extremely short term and they'll just auger you into the ground
in the medium to long term.
So if you're acting in your own self interest,
let's take that apart.
Over what period of time your self interest in the next second you're self
interest in the next hour.
Like if you're impulsive and you want to gratify an impulse,
you're obviously acting in your self interest in the next second or the next two
seconds or the next minute.
But you know you'll pay for that.
Maybe you punch someone or you slap someone cause you're so angry and they,
you know,
and they knock you for a loop and then they charge you with assault.
You know,
so well it was great in your self interest in the second,
but like future,
remember that Simpsons episode,
homer drank a quart of Manet's and vodka and margin.
All his kids were telling him not to and he said,
well that's a problem for future homer.
I sure don't envy that guy.
It's like,
which is one of the best Simpson's lines ever,
I think.
And well that's it.
Exactly.
It's like,
well there isn't just you.
There's,
there's now you and there's tonight you and there's tomorrow morning you,
that's the one that'll have the hangover by the way.
And there's next week you and next month you and next year you and old you.
And so if you're going to act in your self interest,
you have to take that collective of use across time into account when you make
your decision.
And now here's the cool thing about that.
So then that say well that would be acting in your self interest writ large
right across time spans,
but the thing is future you and someone else that you have to live with right
now that's not,
you are pretty much the same people.
And so if you're going to act in your self interest and you have other people
around you,
then you also want to act in their self interest because otherwise they won't
like you,
they won't cooperate with you and they won't compete with you in a reasonable
manner.
And so that's going to be a catastrophe.
And so you want to act out what's good for you now and what's good for you next
month and next year and you want to do that in a way that's good for you and
your family and your community right now.
Next week and next year and you're going to take all of those things into
account at the same time.
That's an equivalent rated game from Piaget,
Gideon and perspective,
and it was his idea that that constituted the basis for proper moral judgment
and it's a brilliant idea.
It's a brilliant idea.
And so that's your true self interest.
There's no difference between your interest in the interest of others,
not in any fundamental sense,
even your enemies,
which is why you're enjoying to treat your enemy as if he was yourself.
Because he is,
you know,
when you think,
well,
you should wish,
you should wish your enemies well.
Well why?
Well,
it isn't that you hope they get a bigger house than you.
It's that let's say you're,
you're being pursued and tormented by someone who's truly reprehensible.
That person is,
they have a miserable life man.
In all likelihood,
let's say they're truly malevolent,
you know they live in hell and what you might hope for them is that they could
figure out how to get out of there cause it's not good for them and it's not
good for anyone else think.
Well,
even your enemies,
it's like,
wouldn't it be good if they could get their act together and stop being so
unnecessarily malevolent?
And that's in your self interest.
So the idea that your self interest is somehow opposed to other people's or that
if you maximize yourself interest,
you're not operating in the best interest of other people is predicated on a
poor idea of what constitutes your self interest because you're not separate in
any real sense from other people.
You maybe not separate from everything in some real sense.
You know,
I mean young,
young in his book mysterium connectionists he had this idea,
I'm going to go through it real quick.
It's a complicated idea that this is how you put yourself together.
The first thing you do is you,
you join your emotions and your,
and your rationality.
So that,
so that your mind and your emotions are one thing he called out the first
conjunction.
Um,
so that your motivations and your emotions and the way that you think about the
world are all acting in the same direction.
Okay?
So that's the first conjunction and you get your act together that way.
So that would mean incorporation of aggression and sexuality from a Freud in
perspective,
those parts of you that are difficult to integrate come to be integrated into
one thing.
So you can use your anger when you need to and you have your sexuality under
control.
It doesn't have you,
but you know how to use it and it's a power for you.
Um,
and,
and you're properly assertive in all of those things.
And so you build yourself into one psychological unit and then you embody that.
So that's the second conjunction.
The second conjunction is take your mind,
emotion,
motivation,
unity,
and acted out,
acted out in the world so that there's no distinction between you and what you
do between you and the way you think about the world and your philosophy and how
you act.
That makes you a second kind of unity.
And then the final conjunction,
which is the most difficult one,
is to stop thinking that the world is different than you are.
This is why I ask people to clean up the rooms.
It's like your room is you,
it's you.
And so you go in there and you up your room,
your cleaning you up to the same way you're developing discipline,
you're putting yourself in order,
you're developing a vision of the future.
You're figuring out how to dress,
you're figuring out how to take care of your things.
You're interacting with the micro cosmos that you have in front of you and
learning how to balance chaos and order.
There's no difference between you and what's around you and that's a very
difficult thing to understand and so you want to act in a way that's good for
you but good for everything else at the same time and that's,
that's a high moral virtue and that so there is there.
That's the right way of thinking about the relationship between psychological
egoism and altruism.
It's like if you're,
as you move towards a broader conceptualization of things,
you start to understand that there is no selfish selfish,
there is no selfish self interest.
It isn't how life works.
Like if you're married to someone for example,
and you're stuck with them for the next 50 years,
it's like you can't win an argument with them.
You can make peace because there you man,
there you,
there are a huge part of your experience.
You have to treat that person as if they are you and then live.
It's not,
it isn't like,
well I'm going to treat you well because you're me.
It's because people don't treat themselves very well.
Often it's way more complicated than that.
You just,
you don't want to defeat your wife man,
because then you live with a defeated wife and if you think she isn't going to
take revenge on you,
then you're,
you're not very bright.
So you want to listen to what she has to say and you want to listen to her
problems and you want to help her solve them because she's you and you want to
do the same with your kids and then you want to do the same with the people
around you if you can do it so and so the whole idea of like,
well,
we're basically wired to be selfish.
Well we are when we're not very wise and we act impulsively.
But as your view of the world broadens,
you start to understand that this is why in the Buddhist philosophy,
you know,
Buddha attain Nirvana.
So that meant he could stay in union with the gods,
so to speak.
He,
he attained the highest form of,
of subjective experience,
what might be,
which might be something like total immersion in bliss and meaning.
But he rejected it because he went back into the world to help other people
attain nirvana or at least to move towards it because he realized that there was
no individual redemption without the redemption of all.
And you,
if you don't understand that,
then you're just not very wise.
And so you're trying to be a force for good in the world.
And that doesn't mean just good for you.
That's just,
it's just blind because there isn't any isolated you that isn't how things are
that is now realities lays itself out.
So.